good morning
the um you you folks are at the
subcommittee
um hearing for
um HB 232 which is
um addressing private sector
um OSHA standards and
um at this point
um what we are looking to do is adopt
the OSHA standards without necessarily
going
um full out for a state plan
and we had a study committee
um
uh
when a year ago
and that study committee
got shortened up substantially more than
we would have liked and so the committee
chose to retain the bill so that we
could get more input from
um the the stakeholders so um that's why
we are here and I'm looking out I'm
seeing stakeholders so that's uh that's
a good thing
um and essentially what uh by adopting
the um uh the OSHA standards what we're
suggesting we want to do is to adopt the
1910 standards and those are the general
um uh the general standards there's two
other categories but we felt this was
the most appropriate one it is a
substantial list of Standards
[Music]
um
we've got Wes from the Department here
and we've got him to thank for doing a
side-by-side comparison of the OSHA
standards in the department of labor
standards and um
what um that is available to folks
um the the comparison it is a fairly
large file
um it's not something you're going to
want to print out unless you've got a
lot of paper
um but uh essentially
um I've forwarded it to Kristen and
um who is the committee committee
assistant and
um she would be happy to send it out to
anybody
um who would like to have a copy of it I
also have it so if you want to contact
me Brian Sullivan representative Brian
Sullivan I'd be happy to send it out as
well
but there are I think you will find that
there are a lot of standards that don't
apply to
um the uh the various employers so you
can find the standards that are most
applicable to whatever type of
employment you're involved with
um
so with that I would be happy to open it
up to folks who would like to weigh in
on um if you've got questions if you've
got concerns if you've got suggestions
um we're uh we're here to listen so
um
anybody out there want to
talk to the committee
if you could introduce yourself as you
come up please
hi my name is Susie Nord and I work for
the National Council for occupational
safety and health and I was going to
wait for other people because I feel
like I have had the opportunity to
address the committee about why National
Kosh supports I was spelled 232 and has
in fact been working towards
helping the state of New Hampshire adopt
a public sector OSHA plan and I feel
like this is a good next step in that
but where nobody else decided to come up
I thought I would just tell you I've
been doing a little research which I
said that I would do at the last time I
was in a hearing to address some of the
questions I'd heard and I wanted to let
you know what had come of that
so one of the things that
people were most concerned about was how
OSHA standards which are mostly for
private sector interact with public
services such as police and fire
um which don't necessarily seem like
they're a good fit and I found a number
of things first of all nobody I I should
back up a little bit my organization
um has a list served for health and
safety Professionals of about 2 000
people across the country who work in
health and safety occupational
health
professionals such as doctors lawyers
industrial hygienists people who are on
health and safety committees in
workplaces and also many workers as well
who are involved in health and safety in
their own organizations so I put the
question out how does a public sector
OSHA plan interact specifically with
fire safety or police
and I heard from a number of people
including one person who was actually
recently retired from the Washington
State
OSHA plan so this is a person who has
um in the state of Washington they have
a public sector OSHA plan and she was
um
one of the people who administered it
and she basically said that they never
had any problems with dealing with
um fire and police specifically because
they worked very closely with the um
fire and police departments to adopt
sort of the national standards and
there's acronyms that I won't bore you
with but mostly because I can't remember
them that
um
are actually more
um protective than what is in the 1910
standards and so I don't think that any
of that as long as we're following
national standards for protecting our
fire and police officers should be a
problem because they're probably already
doing more than these would require
anyway
um I she did give me a couple of
interesting examples I'll tell you about
one of them that um they worked with
their state police about lead
at the firing range because apparently
there was um concerns about the amount
of lead from when they fire the bullets
apparently bullets have led I
am not a gun person so I don't know but
um so that was something that having the
the they call it Dosh there it's the
department of Occupational Health in
Washington Dash or wadosh and that was
something that they worked on that
wasn't covered by
existing police standards but that you
know that it was a a benefit that having
the the public sector OSHA added for
their state police
I guess the other thing that I really
want to highlight is that I've spoken to
people who work with some of the public
sector employers since
the original hearings on this bill and I
think there's a misunder or
mischaracterization that this is
creating new
things for public sector employers to
actually
have to comply with because
um my reading an understanding is that
the Department of Labor the New
Hampshire Department of Labor has
um
an understanding that public sector
employers will keep their workers safe
and that they are charged with ensuring
that this happens and so they do
inspections and go out and this is
nothing new the only thing new is that a
few years ago it was put into statute
instead of just being in rules and
there's a number for the rules and I
don't know that either
um
and that my understanding from the
former Deputy Commissioner Rudy Ogden
was that
the OSHA standards that we're looking to
incorporate into
um
House Bill 232 are one of the places
that they look when the New Hampshire
standards are silent
because it gives them sort of a
meaningful
guideline or guidance for the employers
and so the idea my understanding from
the the study committee last year and
the reason that this study committee
unanimously supported the concept of
what house bill 232 does is that most
public sector employers didn't
necessarily know that this was one of
the places that the Department of Labor
inspectors were going for
guidance when doing their inspections
and so
the committee or the study committee
last year believed that this bill
was basically not requiring anything
specifically new it was saying
let's make public the standards that
people are being held to currently
so without and I'll take any questions
but those are the two points that I
really have sort of been thinking about
this summer and really feel like in my
discussions with people those are two
points of clarity I felt needed to be
made
any questions from the committee
thank you
um
perhaps if
the department is willing to
Enlighten us further on the general
duties clause and how that interacts
with the department of labor standards
and any other standards including the
OSHA standards yes of course
um Wesley Gardner attorney for the New
Hampshire Department of Labor so um as
we just testified to we do have the
general duties Clause that kind of fills
in the gaps where we don't have specific
safety standards and again to clarify
our safety inspectors do look to OSHA
1910 1926 and 1928 where applicable and
again it is for guidance though I think
the key point of Distinction here is if
the committee and the legislature were
to adopt this it does become law and
it's no longer simply guidance but yes I
can clarify and confirm that what our
safety inspectors do when they see a gap
in our specific safety standards they
will look to the OSHA standards as well
as other national standards just to see
um
what might be appropriate in certain
specific situations
can you um
clarify
when the DOL standards have last been
updated and modified
one second here
so of course you know it depends on each
specific statute from what I can tell
the last update was 2019 for any of the
uh RSA 277 standards
um but again some of them have not been
updated since um you know the 1980s or
the 1990s
I've seen seem to recall that Deputy
Commissioner Ogden indicated that the
for the most part hadn't really been
updated since he's been with the
Department which was I think 10 years or
more yes that is correct I do remember
Deputy Commissioner Ogden testifying to
that again there's been a handful of the
RSA 277 Provisions that have been
updated but by and large many of the
provisions have not been updated in some
time
and would you agree that one of the
advantages might be that OSHA standards
are continuously being updated and would
if we adopt the 1910 standards they
would be
um updated regularly and automatically
adopted yes as I understand it it's an
annual thing that the OSHA standards are
updated
um they're they're constantly being
updated I can tell you that the
department myself and Deputy
Commissioner Ogden met with Joe Larose
who's the field supervisor for OSHA
um at the federal level and he did state
that they are constantly being updated
on an annual basis so that is something
that um the department as well as uh all
the stakeholders would have to be
mindful of that this is a constant
rolling update
um in the standards that are being
implemented
is the department able to assist
employers public sector Employers in um
keeping track of those updates
I would say the department is able to
however the caveat being that uh current
state we have two safety inspectors with
a third position open
um obviously the three safety inspector
positions were intended to implement uh
chapter 277 as currently written and as
our safety standards are currently
written so it's inevitable that there
will probably be a lot more interest
from stakeholders in trying to comply
with the new standards so we do have
minimal capacity as it relates to
implementation of these laws in the
sense that we would expect that a lot of
stakeholders will have a lot of
questions that want consultancies to
determine if they are in compliance so
to your specific question yes I do
believe that the department can assist
employers however again the capacity at
current state is rather minimal again
given that our three safety inspector
positions were intended to support
chapter 277 as it's currently written
I seem to recall that uh Deputy
commission commissioner Ogden had
indicated that along with the adoption
of 232 the department would like likely
hire additional Personnel do are you
familiar with that yes I am familiar
with that and if I call correctly from
the committee last year Deputy
Commissioner Ogden and testified he
believed that we would need
approximately six new positions
um I believe there would be one safety
manager position
three inspector positions
one clerical position
and two consultant positions if I
remember correctly
can you indicate how that would impact
the general fund
so I don't think it would impact the
general fund in the sense of the
Department of Labor historically does
not take from the general fund rather
over the last few years we've given to
the general fund however of course any
new positions would you know cost more
money at the end of the day but it
should not have any impact on the
general fund specifically to my
knowledge yeah I was surprised to learn
sorry absent the the give back that the
department does would inevitably be
lower of course but I was surprised to
learn that the department doesn't use
General funds
and also I think Deputy Commissioner
Ogden indicated that due to
um
a
more
a a bigger effort on part of on part of
the Department of collecting I think fee
fees and and such they had gone from
having a million dollars that they sent
back to more like two or three is I
believe the number this year was closer
to three million yes yeah so
I think you could probably squeeze a few
additional employees out of three
million dollars potentially again caveat
just being that that's less that goes to
the general fund from the Department
right
uh questions from the committee
okay all right thank you thank you Mr
Gardner
the floor is open to other
um
folks to speak their mind
Miss Horgan anything on behalf of the
Committees are the counties
um
thank you representative Sullivan Kate
Horgan from the New Hampshire
Association of counties I will actually
have five people here next week to
address the committee several HR
managers uh won the correction
superintendents and one of our nursing
home administrators who can more
accurately address any questions you
guys all have um so I would defer if you
are willing to let me to defer until
next week when I have my subject matter
experts here that would be great I think
you should do it all right now
[Laughter]
um okay thank you that's that's good to
know thank you
anyone else
and he can
anything from the Department of
administrative services
we're good okay
it's starting to feel like a short day
yep please
it's a little bit embarrassing for me to
ask but can you please refresh my memory
of why we're going the route of
going the OSHA 1910 standards rather
than looking at updating our current
safety standards that we have under
chapter 277.
I think well the initial effort was to
create a state plan which would have um
basically
um
brought the public sector employees
under OSHA um it was a fairly involved
process the subcommittee or the study
committee uh chose to adopt just the
OSHA standards rather than
um uh
rather than going for the state plan
because it's a more streamlined process
um
and I frankly we what by adopting the
OSHA standards we save a lot of time and
effort on on the part of the department
and obviously the department hasn't been
updating its standards and this would be
a a sweeping update
and
basically I I think the study committee
felt that a change was in order the
failure to update
over the last many years is something
that needed to be addressed and we felt
the best way to address it was to Simply
adopt the standards from OSHA
and and I think the the other the other
piece of it is is already been stated
but I think it's worth restating the
department uses a general duties Clause
pretty regularly when
um addressing
um safety issues
um and um and there are lots of gaps I
mean if if one were to review the uh
side-by-side comparison it does identify
a lot of things that OSHA covers that
the department of labor standards does
not but when an unsafe situation is
identified where there's a gap in the
department of labor standards they turn
to OSHA
um the problem is that um if some If an
employer or employee group is reviewing
the department of labor standards they
wouldn't know that the general duties
Clause is going to cause
the department to look look to the OSHA
standard so if if they're already using
OSHA standards in various circumstances
it's
worthwhile for people to know that if
you want to really see the standards
look to the 1910 standards and that will
provide the guidance needed
you may
um
on that topic I think it's important
that the work of this committee
characterize that we we heard some
General discussion before and you kind
of reiterated that that some of the
anticipated cost isn't really cost
because today we expect all the
employers to have a safe environment for
their workers and and that's not going
to change but as this advances to the
larger bodies and goes across the wall I
think it's you and I and and many of us
here have been working on this for years
and years and we understand that all
that background but I think it's going
to be important to characterize that in
a way that everyone can evaluate that
and when a town or a county says whoa
this is downshifting costs from the
state to us and our tax base that we
know how to
um
explain that in in terms of hard facts
and I hope I I appreciate that that
you'll want to have
um experts come and and help explain
that to us rather than summarize to it
so I hope that in the next meeting that
we'll be able to
uh come to some kind of understanding
that then this committee can use to
explain to the the legislature at Large
why we think this is the right idea
thank you
I may
um can we go back to Mr Garner if I have
your name correctly
um and just get a little bit more
information I'm a little curious about
the the Labor Statistics with what we
currently have we have two inspectors
with one empty position to be filled but
if we adopt OSHA 1910 standards then we
need to fill six positions why would
there be a disparity between what we're
doing today in our safety program versus
what this OSHA 1910 is going to bring
my apologies thank you for the question
represent so one of the key distinctions
there is
um one is the consultancy program OSHA
does require a consultancy program that
um the state of New Hampshire doesn't
currently have
um so again we would need a couple of
Consultants that they basically
um go out to the employers and they kind
of review what they have for safety
standards their safety plans and they go
over them and tell them how they might
come into compliance again it's wide
sweeping regulation so that's this
assistance is necessary the other piece
of it as well too is given the wide
sweeping nature of it we would just
simply need more inspectors
um you know as the committee is probably
aware and has been testified to the 277
standards a relatively minimal in
comparison to the OSHA standards and
there also needs to be more subject
matter expertise I would say as well too
so that's why we would need more um and
again the clear another point of
clarification as well is when Deputy
Commissioner Ogden testified to that
last year that was very specific to the
state plan implementation which is not
merely just the 1910s so I would say we
don't need all six positions where we to
adopt the 1910s but in going towards the
state plan that was the intention for
what Deputy Commissioner Ogden stated as
the expansion and it to be clear this
bill does not create a state plan
correct this this bill just adopts the
standards if we were to adopt um this or
create a state plan that would be
something down the road who would
require additional legislation and um
but at this point the the study
committee was comfortable with uh and
frankly
um the States of Maine and
Massachusetts
have both just adopted State plans but
prior to adopting the state plans they
adopted the OSHA of safety standards so
um it seems like it worked effectively
for for them we would not ever
necessarily have to adopt a state plan I
can see
legislatures in the future
wanting to consider that because Federal
money comes along with the state plan
but for now
um it as has been said this is a good
Next Step getting the standards in and
then down the road if we so choose we
could adopt the
uh or create a state plan
um but this this doesn't do that that's
correct and so possibly all six of those
positions would not be needed at this
time that's correct again the point of
clarity is that when Deputy Commissioner
Ogden testified to the
um guess of six additional employees for
the Department that was based on the
state plan but again uh the department
is able to implement this but we will be
stretched thin with the two current
safety inspectors and again the big
piece of it is the consultancy program
that we do not currently have the safety
inspectors do go they help evaluate
employers plans their safety rules and
get them into compliance but it's not a
full consultancy program by any means
and but the
um
HB 232 does to my knowledge does not
create a consultancy program that is
correct however we anticipate that many
of these stakeholders will reach out to
the department in essence looking for a
consultancy to ensure that they're in
compliance before they get a com the
department gets a complaint an inspector
has to go out there and cite them for
violations yeah we expect them to be
proactive great yep
and I believe you mentioned an admin
position as well what would the need for
the additional administrative position
be that you don't have today so I'm
assuming you're speaking of like the
safety manager position the Deputy
Commissioner Deputy Commissioner Ogden
identified
or or a clerical position yeah it's it's
just the fact of having multiple more
several more inspectors the consultancy
program and just having uh admin
position to support that
but that's all it is and the consultancy
program if I'm understanding correctly
doesn't sound like it's going to be a
permanent long-term position it sounds
more like it would be a short term so
the consultancy program is a piece of
the OSHA state plan as I understand it
that is required to have and maintain a
state plan and receive federal funding
so if the intent were to eventually go
to a state plan of course that would
have to be in place
um
more than likely it's hard to say though
overall of what the volume of
stakeholder reach out would be and
whether it would be just an initial one
to two year thing where this new um new
legislation is in place so it is hard to
say
um but I do know
at least again for the ocean state plan
and OSHA regulations in general the
consultancy program is a very key piece
of that because a lot of employers again
are proactive in reaching out to
determine if they are in compliance
before God forbid an accident happens or
a complaint comes in and the inspector
has to go out there
Federal funding looks like what is it
that we're looking for for this Federal
funding so as I understand it the
federal funding what happens is when a
state implements a state OSHA plan
they've been working usually for years
with Federal OSHA if Federal OSHA
approves the state plan and finds that
the standards are either the same or as
at least as effective then the state can
apply to the federal government and as I
understand it does have to be an
application it's not automatic the state
can apply to the federal government for
up to 50 percent of federal funding and
as I understand it it's at the
discretion of the federal government of
how much funding it is again it goes up
to 50 percent it can be anything lower
than 50 percent though and there's no
guarantee for federal funds and in light
of that as well too the state does have
to keep a rolling update to make sure
that they're in compliance with Federal
OSHA standards and that the standards
are at least as effective to maintain
getting receipt of that Federal funding
and what are some of the things that we
would be using these Federal funding for
is it for buying equipment or is it for
Staffing it would be for Staffing and
supporting the positions by and large
yes um as I as I understand it the
department wouldn't need any more
equipment I don't believe maybe State
cards is the only thing I can really
think of generally
um but there's there's no other
equipment that I can think of off the
top of my head that we would need so the
funding would be for State positions and
just implementing the plan in general
and as I understand it when you say 50
percent it's 50 percent of the entire
public sector safety program that is how
I understand it as well yes
are we receiving any federal funds now
we are receiving no federal funds now
if I could I just want to make it clear
that the proposal on the table in front
of us comes with no federal fund we
would not be eligible that
for that there's nothing in here that
says we would work towards that
eligibility or submit that application
um we did in the first version of this
Bill if you will to come through the
legislature that was the proposal and
that's why many of us are at least
passingly familiar with what the
requirements are
um but
over the years this committee has
decided not to go that route and we
could get into the details
um let's just not to be controversial
say there were questions whether that
would be a net gain or a net cost
because that funding also comes with
requirements
would it pay for their requirements and
then some would it pay for almost all
the requirements we we hadn't clarified
that number and this committee decided
to go a different route which was to
implement it all within
state law which then makes us ineligible
at least at this time to work through
that Federal program so discussions
about what federal money is available
and what it would pay for are for
something very different than what we're
considering and I think some of the
other
attraction was done frankly
um not necessarily involve oship in New
Hampshire safety programs this would be
the Department of Labor implementing
OSHA the OSHA standards without
the help or interference of federal
oship so it gets us enhanced standards
without having to jump through all the
various Hoops that OSHA would require
with the state plan I think that's why
the study committee was comfortable
going this route rather than the state
plan let's let's do it ourselves let's
adopt the standards and you know stick
with our department labor and and their
method of doing things because I think
one of the
um
one of the nice Parts about our
department of labor is that it is not
overly punitive
it when it finds um
issues with safety their objective is to
get it fixed not to punish
um and I think that's something that we
want to make sure we maintain and um
it it'll be more of a education process
than a wacky over the head process so um
I
I think that that was the attraction to
doing it in the manner that we are
yep thank you
anything further we're all ears here
thank you Mr chairman I apologize I was
late coming in if you're just taking
open
yeah okay uh for the record Brian
Hawkins representing Nea New Hampshire
we represent uh K-12 employees in most
school districts in the state and so
obviously uh safety standards would have
uh an important impact for our members
um schools are first and foremost place
for places for students but there are
also places of employment and so we
would very much like to work with the
committee help the committee to the
extent they need information
um one of the benefits of being part of
an uh affiliate of a National
Organization is we also have the benefit
of
you know knowing what the experience is
like in other states for employees in
schools that either are an OSHA state or
you know have safety standards that are
comparable to OSHA and so
um
mainly want to say we're
eager to work with the committee and
um hope to attend all your sessions and
please let us know what information we
can help provide great and I would also
suggest that if you enhance safety
standards for the teachers you
inevitably enhance safety standards for
the students as well so they're all in
the same boat so I think enhanced safety
is uh is good for schools indeed
any questions from the committee
thank you thank you
if there are no other uh folks who want
to weigh in on this
um I guess we will adjourn for uh today
and uh come back next week and look
forward to hearing from um uh
any employers or employee groups that uh
want to weigh in we just want to
what we heard at the end of the study
committee or
yeah well basically when we were dealing
with this bill
um was that people wanted an opportunity
to do this so that we are providing that
opportunity and looking forward to
hearing from folks
we are adjourned thank you
foreign